a lot of people out there think that
Andy Richter is a very nice easygoing
guy and I got to say he really is is he
very much dry yeah no he is just he's a
good easygoing guy but there's another
layer of Andy that's important to know
about a layer where he really wants
people to think he's a guy who cares
passionately about American culture
that's that's something well I I care
that people think I care yeah exactly
so Andy asked me he said he wanted to
take a moment to address some of the
things that everyone's talking about
these days and I thought it was an okay
idea you ready for this Eddie
I'm ready Conan directa pretends to care
deeply about stuff he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about congratulations on your baby
Chloe and Tristan you need to stop your
tomcatting ways
I hope Prince Harry and Meg and Markel
are happy together it matters to me if
only Ricky Fowler had won the Masters my
neighbor's having a birthday party for
her dog scoots and I want to bring the
perfect gift
why is Coachella always light unnamed
brand country music acts
it's Ron Howard gonna ruin the Star Wars
franchise or take it to a whole new
level but most of all I hope Conan has a
great show
he deserves all his success I'm a big
fan
[Applause]
what was that last one you know Kona is
a good show where's that something no
one would give a [ __ ] about no it's just
I don't give okay good
he saved it again
you